as covid continues to surge in nevada
state leaders are starting to look at
whether recent mitigation efforts
have had an impact on the spread of
coronavirus kate houston has that report
it's been just over three weeks since
governor sisolak announced stay at home
2.0
the two-week initiative was put in place
to try to bring down the surging numbers
of kovid 19
in the state on a wednesday call with
nevada health response the team
addressed the drop in covid 19 cases
from this time last week
and whether or not that's a result of
recent mitigation efforts
caleb cage the nevada kovid 19 response
director
says it's important to look at these
numbers in terms of trends over time
there's always a two to three week lag
when a case is identified and
when we start reporting them there is
also a two to three week lag
for when we start to see mitigation
measures or when we could start to see
mitigation measures
take hold cage says they're unsure if
the decrease is due to a lower number of
people getting tested over the holidays
or from any changes in who went to get
tested it certainly does not
include any of the impacts that we may
or may not see
from thanksgiving so all of that is to
say yes
a decrease in a thousand cases is
positive but it is too early to
call this a trend or to even see what
the causes of that might be
with this in mind it may be a few more
weeks before we start to see the effects
of statewide mitigation efforts
including the recent statewide pause put
in place by governor sislak
kate houston 8 news now nevada health
response
announced updated cdc guidance on
quarantine periods new guidelines state
individuals can go back to normal
activities
after a seven day period if they tested
negative starting on day five of
quarantine
this also applies to individuals after
10 days if they are asymptomatic and
testing
is not available